l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur Michel well qui étaé
transmise à madame la ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé
Monsieur Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
l'article 18 de la loi du 17 décembre
2012 de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 affilie tous les élus
locaux régime général de la Sécurité
sociale pour l'ensemble des risques
maladie vieillesse accident du travail
maladie professionnelle et assujettil
les indemnités de fonction de certains
d'entre eux au cotisations de sécurité
sociale depuis le 1er janvier 2013
sontujettis aux cotisations de sécurité
sociale les indemnité de fonction des
élus n'ayant pas suspendu leur activité
professionnelle pour se consacrer à leur
mandat à savoir à ceux exerçant une
activité professionnelle ceux à la
retraite ceux en situation de chômage
dont le mononde montant total brut est
supérieur à 1543 € par mois ce qui est
la moitié du plafond de la sécurité
sociale et ce à partir du 1emer O
cependant si l'élu cesse ou suspend
toute activité professionnelle pour
l'exercice de son mandat ces ces
indemnités sont assujettis aux
cotisations de sécurité sociale même si
leur montant est inférieur à 50 % du
plafond de l'ASS
l'assugétissement aux cotisations de
sécurité sociale est applicable bien sûr
aux indemnités se rapportant au mandat
débutant à compté du 1er janvier 2013 et
ce en cours pour la période de mandat
postérieur à cette date un rappel de
cotisation à côté du 1er janvier 2013
aura donc été effectué pour toutes les
indemnités ce texte ouvre le débat sur
la qualification du mandat d'élus local
de
proximité alors qu'il n'existe toujours
pas de statut l'élu local
comme une profession alors que dans la
réalité il n'est pas une profession il
n'est pas un métier ni une activité
salariée mais un engagement citoyen
traditionnellement les indemnités visent
donc à compenser les frais engagés la
disponibilité nécessaire et la perte de
revenus occasionné par le temps consacré
à leur mandat en plus ce changement est
inclus dans la partie recette de la loi
de la sécurité sociale est importante et
impacte importante et impacte les
budgets personnels et institutionnels le
coût correspondant n'est pas à noin les
charges patronales supplémentaires de
28,6 % minimum et pour les élus une
réfaction de 7,60 % minimum sur leur
indéinité madame la ministre les
conséquences de ces mesures sont donc
importants pour nombre d'élus aussi je
vous demande de bien vouloir procéder à
une révision de ce
texte merci mer mon cher collègue madame
la
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur well comme vous
avez pu l'évoquer dans votre question
c'est bien l'article 18 de la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 qui a prévu l'affiliation au régime
général de la Sécurité sociale des élus
locaux et des délégués des collectivités
territoriales membres d'un établissement
public de coopération intercommunale
cette disposition poursuit un souci
d'équité et améliore la PR sociale des
élus locaux la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a également assujéti
les indemnités de fonction de ces élus
aux cotisation d'assurance sociale des
accidents du travail et des allocations
familiales cet assujettissement au
premier OS intervient dès lors que le
montant total des indemnités de fonction
dépasse une fraction de la valeur du
plafond de la sécurité sociale ou que
l'élu suspend son activité
professionnelle pour l'exercice de son
mandat le décret 2013 362 du 26 avril
2013 relatif aux conditions
d'affiliation des élus locaux au régime
général de la Sécurité Sociale a fixé le
seuil d'assugettissement à la moitié du
Pass ce qui correspond à une indemnité
mensuel total de 1543 €. les élus
percevant un total d'indemnité de
fonction inférieure à ce seuil mensuel
2543 € comme c'est le cas notamment pour
les maires des communes de moins de 1000
habitants ou les adjoints aux Mair des
communes de moins de 50000 habitants ne
sont donc pas concernés par cette
nouvelle cotisation les élus locaux dont
les indemnités sont assujettis au régime
général de la Sécurité sociale verront
leur couverture sociale améliorée par la
perception de prestation en nature et en
espèce au titre de l'assurance maladie
maternité accident du travail de trajet
et maladie professionnelle ils pourront
également compléter leur droit à
retraite auprès de l'assurance
vieillesse du régime e général de la
sécurité sociale monsieur le sénateur je
crois qu'il est important de préciser
que le projet de décret a fait l'objet
d'un examen approfondi de la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes au
cours des deux séances qui ont eu lieu
au prier trimestre 2013 une concertation
avec l'association d'élus s'est tenue
également en amont de la publication du
décret c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
souhaite maintenir les améliorations
apportées à leur protection sociale il
n'envisage ainsi pas de modifier le SE
d'assugjettissement fixé par le décret
du 26 avril 2013 concernant plus
largement le statut de l'élu local le
gouvernement séit engagé suite aux états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
organisé par le Sénat en septembre 2012
à soutenir l'initiative prise par votre
assemblée pour l'amélioration des
cotisations d'exercice des mandats
locaux le Sénat a voté la proposition de
loi déposée par Madame Courau et
Monsieur suur le 29 janvier 2013 à avec
le soutien du Gouvernement l'Assemblée
nationale l'a examiné amendé et adopté
le 18 décembre dernier aussi j'ai le
plaisir de vous annoncer que la nouvelle
lecture est prévue ici au Sénat le 22
janvier merci Madame la Ministre allez-y
mon cher collègue
oui madame la ministre je vous remercie
de votre réponse qui va dans mon sens
donc de essayer d'améliorer encore le
texte surtout que ce texte était
nécessaire pour que les élus qui cessent
leur activité puissent avoir la
couverture sociale je crois que c'était
incontournable c'était réclamé depuis
très longtemps et donc j'ai approuvé ce
texte lorsqu'il est passé je suis
heureux de savoir que on va le
retravailler un petit peu merci Monsieur
well